gang still a few dates to hit for that
state trashy tour grab the squad and
come out and see the boys stand up
comedy then we play a little ay with the
crowd grab the squad and come hang the
big man ain't lying it's a great time
and we are coming out we got a bunch of
cities left we got Minneapolis Madison
Milwaukee two shows in Sacramento San
Francisco San Jose Washington then
obviously the we're coming home the
chickens are coming home to roost and
Philadelphia baby at the Filmore get
your tickets gang yeah welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's new favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
they're good to be classy they just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host T
try coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here with toies in the
new edition she's upstairs in a nice
bath okay yeah getting sexy all right I
got nothing my co-host is coming at you
from across the table he is the CEO of
Ru garbage he's International
businessman got a big old forehead give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan and the
ladies love it what's up everybody look
at that thing hey thanks a lot jelly
roll thanks for tuning in
everybody make sure you R you subscribe
on iTunes over there which we're
climbing up the charts finally getting
finally getting some respect over there
on the charts uh and then uh full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are true to R cooking cooking
then obviously the greatest website of
all time you head over there you pull
out your laptop your desktop your dude
you're getting a Dell your
gateway
www.patreon.com garbage you go over
there you get a bajillion 1.92 bajillion
hours of content there's a lot going on
over there you're not lying I know I
ain't lying that's why I said it I Li
man never lies keep an yeah right you're
[__] Whitey Fisk over here gang how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer short and air the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours he
crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
and he thinking something mean to say to
me right now give it up for T-Bone MCC
scruffs Toby McMullen what's up dude I
really was what up TBO I know you are
dude the roll up of the jacket stinks
the sleeves are too long it's it's like
the worst candy of all time denim
rollups oh man why why did you think he
was going to give you that I don't care
I don't care I do it for the people out
there man I'll give you that hey he's a
man of the people Den rollups the
numbers were putting up these days denim
rollups got two three laughs out in the
wild that joke was that joke was a real
gusher oh my God come on it does look
like you Dro something behind a couch
and you're like hang on let me get back
yeah here's the deal all right and I've
mentioned this before on on on on on
this very program pull some sort of
sympathy card you can't find a jacket
that wide with sleeves that short yeah
that's really what it is that's what's
that from the Andre the Giant
collection now that's a
bit Us's the He-man toy as a model
what's going on over there how you doing
stretch listen here's the story I could
become a billionaire in the men's in the
larger men's clothing fashion business
uh get me in there what's stopping you
Capital IQ
General knoow technology the goddamn
government fcking all over me kid me a
lot of people wouldn't mind having me
out it away I'll tell you that yeah if
you were going to start a business
what's your first play you're like all
right I'm going to get in I'm going to
get into the you you now that you're
losing some weight you're looking good
you're looking fresh he's going to ask
you for money yeah what's the first boom
like I'm going to all right I'm going to
I'm I'm going to do it I made some
sketches some loose stuff I have some
ideas what's the first call uh uh and I
don't exist who you call I'm call Patty
see what cass's doing Tommy C call Patty
have a heater over the phone that's also
real trash you and your mom do you have
you have zoom sigs together you're out
there you're each go we'll go have
you're having telephone sigs she my good
friend that's all I got I got her and
Tommy C and I'm with him most of the
time so I can't call him in chitchat so
I call Patty and we Yap a little bit boy
you're you're starting a business Who
you calling honestly I was starting a
business I said I I he said he was
Reinventing the big andall store from
the ground up yeah which I think I could
do with connect it with the right people
I think I have really good ideas you you
got to you can't make the [__] I
don't know who this is for sounds like a
great idea there's guys that are as big
as me that their arms aren't that long
you got to shorten up the sleeves a
little bit and use better fabric they're
all over the place sometimes they're
good sometimes you how how hard sourcing
that much textile is you've said that
before and I understand that but you
need go-getters on the team I think what
you should do you're you're as a problem
solver kind of guy I am you're looking
at it you're trying to solve the wrong
problem you're trying to Source make
cool stuff by the way one of these
companies hit me up crazy to do some
[__] modeling you got to be top 400
famous fat guys at this point get me on
a [__] print that will youit them up
I'll throw the sweater over the shoulder
to hold nine oh man it's crazy that I'm
not [__] work and print work I should
be walking Runway too rolling just a
bunch of fat guys on Rascals do they
have big and tall uh runways fashion
shows probably I can see your face on a
bus sure there you go double
decker sandwich bastard I a I get my
boom box um you're thinking about this
the wrong way what you need to be
thinking about I'm not thinking about
nothing they should hire me didn't you
start this by saying you got some great
ideas they should hire me as a
consultant I can give them some fat guy
in information I feel like they're all
skinny Minis that are doing it doing the
work over there there's no way you think
they're big dudes yeah well they're
jamming me
up the [__] arms are too long so I
got to do the roll up and if I do just
the one roll up I look like I'm late for
school or something like that it looks
like they don't fit like when I had my
jeans and Patty wouldn't get them hemmed
she would just tuck them under the worst
the tuck under doesn't even last to the
bus stop you that thing you think you
stand there the the T obviously the
rooll the outward roll to show the cuff
but the tuck in you think's going to
hold and when you're standing still like
a fat little kid looking in the mirror
you're like this will be I'm going be
able to get away with this buddy oh man
first period comes when when the outward
roll and Tuck became fashionable in the
early
90s that was man that saved my life sure
it wasn't cool when you were in school
no but I do know that I'm talking where
you fold it in tight roll I think
they're called my brother and sister big
tight roll I got to tight roll my pants
that and a pair of like nice Timberland
boots mean I was wearing my dad's khakis
at [__] eight years old I go over to
Pat's house to go swimming I have to
swim at Mr sty [__] bathing suit like
a jerk I remember he goes we can go to
my dad see if my dad has anything man
dude [__] pubes in the bathing suit
already little nuts in there grown man
sack just [__] just going [__]
flesh to flesh do you got any intel a
fashion show cuz I'm walking what
fashion show in the big and tall fashion
show I doubt it's in
Paris at Denny probably in Cleveland or
something like that [__] Youngstown
Ohio that'd be all right clean up up
there [__] rust Bel guys all right I
might have a line for you pal what do
you got the the curvy fashionista.com
okay has an article where are big and
tall men at did you know this Expo is
for you there seems to be some sort of
Expo I'm not doing Expo work Runway
print work this was in this was in the
conference room of a Marriott dude this
is bad good bunch of guys eating
omelets Patty um that was at the it was
the Omni Hotel in Atlanta the Omni and
it was in it was at the omelet Hotel in
Atlanta and it was in 2019 I don't think
this idea took off bro damn goddamn
pandemic shutting everything down no
[__] I could help out I'm just saying
start a business what start my own
clothing line I don't know you I'd have
to have somebody in the clothing
business wouldn't I and what am I going
to do differently I'm not telling you
okay I it was more of you you you you
[__] you walk around bagging your
Bible saying you have these great ideas
you got to go thinner material flexible
breathable I don't think for [__] you
want something thin material trust me
you get listen I'm telling you you want
it like so thin no because you wear
through that you get l on your shirt
from the table you need powerful
material you're thinking about this all
that's the problem it's uncomfortable no
this is the you know the one jacket that
I have the tan one that's perfect that's
thin but I had to wash and dry that like
a thousand
times yeah heavy this thing is what
you're this is what I'm saying you're
you're trying to take current fashion
standards and apply them to Fat Guys
what you're doing is need to change the
game for larger gentlemen burlap sacks
make them cool
you got to change what PE the perception
of cool you're playing you're playing
[__] pity Pat Checkers over here need
the sweatsuit to come back get get who's
the most famous fat guy DJ khed get DJ
khed in the burlap sack branded or
something he's not that big though he's
big is he big he's big he probably gets
all his [__] custom made custom made
custom paid or you just custom yeah he
drives rolls-royces and stuff like that
he don't need me no but I'm just saying
if you can get him you got to start
dressing easier you're trying to cram
not this is you're trying to cram 10B of
[__] into a 5B bag that's an idea yes
that's the idea it's 90% you've given me
an idea you're out that's my idea no
I'll give you 3% it's my idea for
$400,000 no points I need to get a hold
of one of these famous fat guys and me
start dressing them and maybe making my
own clothes but who's going to do that
who's going to do the manufacturer you
can't dress yourself yeah we do most of
that for you because I don't have the
right gear CU they don't make it right
you can't buy the right gear so you're
going to make gear I'll just take it to
the
tailor but I don't know if they can
shorten the sleeves do something they're
wizards they [__] yeah they shorten
it up top or something they got to
figure something there's got to be a guy
who can shorten a freaking sleeve they
had some patches maybe yeah American
flag patch Burger King couple Whoppers
on the back some guy with a welders mask
will s you U right yeah [__] Tig weld
that thing yeah uh you know what Patty
did and I I was a little uh questional
about it see what you guys think about
this I'm listening um might have
mentioned this to you but uh I got a
present from Patty the last time that I
was home it was a
blanket what do you think that blanket
was made of
oo oh man this could go one of two or 12
ways I think if you really think about
it you'll get the
answer all right
chocolate
or smokes hemp no maral miles nylon Noy
it's not a material it's not a material
no recycled tires no it's a blanket is
comfortable
no cigarette butts like a bird's nest
yeah anxiety a bunch of my father's old
t-shirts whoa yep I got a death blank
dude that's what they do now who no I
don't know no we've done it in our
family multiple times and I got a pillow
made of a sweatshirt who's making that I
got you the world's saddest quilt yeah
you're nuts what the that's what I said
who wants to dude imagine pulling that
thing up when the lights are out oh my
God smelling [__] brute cologne oh
[__] that feels like the hugs I never
got the last time you gave me plenty of
hugs dude I am
I am
absolutely sked yeah one of the times
when I was home she put the like the
blanket that was that was on my dad in
in his on his bed that was that mended
up on my bed and it was like chilly and
I put it on woke out middle of night I
almost [__] jumped out the window
dude I mean talk about the heie G yeah
I'm not a big ghost that's just heie
jebi
stuff and what are you doing plus now I
fit in all those old t-shirts I'm
stocked up I got a couple of sweet Navy
ones all worn in perfect couple of
stains got to take care of it sure sure
yeah uh where's the blanket right now
better be at the bottom of the sea [__]
that dude it's at my house that thing
ain't coming nowhere near me all right F
his old leave that in a Storia yeah but
I think a lot of people are doing that
now I'm list I'm going to say no and
people I did yeah there are I'm sure 20
people out there have done I wouldn't
say that's a trend
not a bunch of PE I've never heard of
that a lot of people eat snake dude that
doesn't make it normal yeah that's like
you can't uh's good it's good eating
right there talking about um you shut
your mouth I don't know that's we no one
I know in my family's ever done that see
I figured that would be something that
would be in the repertoire over there
Uncle Ernie's favorite shirt they make
it into something like a teddy bear or
something like that who wants that I
don't know that's what I'm saying you
get a
a rest in peace shirt like you're a
rapper or something I'll give you you
know what I mean show up to the crib
proper with an airbrush rest in peace
something for the black back windshield
yeah something to you know [__] free
Yo or something give me something but
uh ah yeah that's a and you're a heie GB
I mean you're a very sentimental very
emotional guy true which I get to play
there but would have rather had the
t-shirts but you're also a big heebie
jeeb guy it's an emotionally weighted
blanket
you never amounted to nothing you fat
piece of [__] just voice you think you
can you think you can design fat guy
clothes how do you feel about that what
uh I don't like any of it man I don't
like happen and then what if you put
like a little voice message in something
for me it's not for me for the if the
kids sure but like like pop loves you
sure I'll give you that [__] good
where my smokes what I'll give you that
but [__] sleep tight yeah but like I
don't need anything from I mean that's
my stepdad's race car like stuff like
that sure but like sure I you don't need
to be she got made into a
blanket we all got
them one's a bathing suit I think man
did she wa did she send that all away
just old on these Jesus I got the skid
mark
Edition God damn yeah and she hears this
she's gonna be pissed Patty I love you
little creeper just saying I I do get
that is a nice very sentimental thing
but it's a lot for me one as a one shirt
made into a pillow like a like a couch
pillow I get that you keep in the
basement I don't I don't need that thing
walking up the stairs to get me no way
that thing's got to be behind closed
doors put put put it in glass like
Annabelle wake up and suffocating you
surrounded by holy
water um yeah that I get I mean like
yeah I don't know that's just very it's
also like I feel like if that thing
caught on fire it would burn blue flames
or some [__] Souls of hogi Past coming
out of it he washed his shirts I know
but like also too like those are like
that's not like fine fabric those are
like
worn they were great teas that I would I
could be kicking right now I could be
rocking them mhm I love when a t-shirt's
nice and broken in sure Tucker te broke
them in nice I get that little couple
games of racket ball how old is it huh
oh okay I think to me a shirt gets a
little too old how old are them he had
t-shirts that's what I'm saying from the
90s yeah in the constant
rotation she get them dry cleaned and
[__] nice starch tea ain't nothing wrong
with his T-shirt game was all right
running around in a ducka shirt vote for
Ros cuz you're the boss or something
cockus I'm surprised you you knew that
oh yeah I know some old
stuff probably family probably voted for
du cockus bunch of hillbillies down
there hell's going
on [__] Hills Have
Eyes [__] Woods people down there
come out once every four years to
[__] vote just put their thumb print
on it make your
mark bunch of bootleggers yeah a lot of
my a lot of my family signed documents
with an X yeah all the towns people
keeping them a bay with
pitchforks get on vote and go vote and
go bunch of whiskey Runners barking at
you a couple of horse two three horse
thieves okay let's talk about manscape
shout out to man skiz aped let's talk
about keeping the front yard and the
backyard looking clean for the Neighbors
you don't want the property value
dropping and they just dropped the 5.0
performance package do yourself a favor
get over to the manscape and pick one up
we're talking about the lawnmower 5.0
Ultra it has two interchangeable blade
heads look at that these guys just keep
innovating it's crazy so you can decide
whether you want to keep a trim or if
you want to go all the way down and keep
a super close shave the way Kippy likes
it I like a nice bald sack and clean be
smooth and clean gang you know we're all
about manscaped over here everybody's
got one everybody uses one do yourself a
favor and pick one up uhuh the
performance package 5.0 5.0 also comes
with the new weed whacker 2.0 ear nose
hair trimmer T-Bone just used before we
recorded this goddamn episode good Lord
uh I got crop uh crop preserver ball
deodorant crop Su love toner and two
plus two free gifts there you go so here
it is here's the tury get 20% off and
free shipping with code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20% off and free
shipping with code garbage at
manscape.com do it gang yeah okay but
talk about ladder shout out the ladder
gang we don't want to stress you out but
we're all going to kick the bucket one
day and you don't want want to leave the
family holding I got lime's disease you
do what you don't want to keep the
family you don't want to leave the
family holding the bag so do yourself a
favor pick up a little term life
insurance over there at ladder no
doctors no needles when you sign up for
$3 million in coverage yeah it's 100%
digital uh like you said no paperwork no
everything could be done online from
your couch just answer a few questions
about your health in an application to
get started and find out if you're
instantly approved and as always there's
no hidden fees you can cancel any time
and even get a full refund if you change
your mind in the first 30 days cuz
ladder's making it easy for you gang
ladder has even made the Forbes best
life insurance 2021 list and it's easy
to see why cuz they're killing in every
aspect of the game there you go go to
ladderlife decom garbage day to see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
ler life.com garbage one more time get a
pen get a pencil pull out your laptop
your phone screaming from the RAF
there's ladderlife decom garbag gang now
do it back to the show to the show God
but all that aside this is a gosh darn
Family episode gang and as you know when
you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on the air
uh patreon gets the first crack at it
cuz they're the mfn homies y I mean I
know what you mean uh all right let's uh
let's get into it this one's from n man
uh $10 Secret inside auditor oo that
means the eyes are on me
dead is it garbage to find out that a
family member is in jail through the
look who in jail section of the County
newspaper we found my uncle in there and
still no one bailed him out ouch that I
kind of respect learn your lesson ice
them down a little bit people used to
always take a peruse through that
section I dude at like 12 or 13 that's
the only thing that interested me ever
who got jammed up who got jammed up and
I always wanted to find someone I knew
or someone's dad or something yeah never
found nothing juicy always look I feel
like that was always on a Sunday they
start talking [__] mhm
[__] running their mouths yeah it was
the paper used to be all right wasn't it
sure yeah the local paper yeah I get one
in the in the BBS that I'm in now I I
caught my I was perusing it really yeah
you start getting it delivered I now it
comes like weekly or monthly or the
whatever the something you know whatever
you paying for it I don't think so it's
mostly by ads it's like you know the
town Gazette or whatever and I love the
local ads the it's you know it's like
jimm he's contracted and he's got like
his son in a headlock or
whatever did did you put your fist
through the wall cuz Eagles didn't cover
call me
oh it's real like uh it's real like used
car dealership Vibes they had no real
marketing person I love it yeah I used
to love the uh the place mat at like
your local Diner that had all the things
on it that might as well been a treasure
map to me man then you see somebody you
know on there like oh [__] [__] Pat's
image of hair styling got cash like that
he also sponsored our little league te
got Diner cash I could use a little
brush clearing uhhuh oh yes some gutter
get your gutters clean when you when
they put down one of those you know
you're in for a nice meal they still at
a reasonable price are they still doing
that I believe so we hit one somewhere
and the breakfast wasn't great they had
the real offbrand ketchup I the offbrand
ketchup I don't remember ah we were
somewhere wait are you talking about
when we film the um oh yes yes yes yes
yes
Storage Wars yeah yeah oh that was off
ketchup yeah we were all Juiced we were
like this place local [__] or something
like that we had a we had a waitress who
was about 12 years old had no idea what
was going on I was in Central Jersey
somewhere yeah yeah you know the one of
the biggest was like flingers or
something like that the it cetch up oh
yeah on paper that place supposed to be
a [__] home it was a place they
Seinfeld go on like Comedians and Cars
like real [__] real old school and
it's stunk we went to a joint made their
own ketchup not that long ago in
Philly boys almost rioted [__] Chris
o Conor does not like homemade ketchup
I'll tell you that there not much he
does like you do hindes you do hind
you're not wrong you do hind I'll take a
hunt I wouldn't I wouldn't kick it out
of bed you do hunt that [__] homemade
[__] get out it always tastes like
cinnamon or coriander or something like
that get out of here with that save that
for the honey mustard wow me some things
just need to come from a factory dude
yeah chicken beef yeah I'm also turning
around on Ken you know Ken Ken's
dressings yeah turning around on them
they're great that was fancy to me no
yeah I gave him a lot of sh they came in
the big pouches I remember seeing my mom
oh those big monster ones my mom will
come home with like the Big Caesar I'm
like God damn what do we hit the what'
you hit the numbers this week toots GE
she working overtime at the hospital did
you guys ever [__] with those uh the
whole salad in a bag that came with the
dressing and little smaller bags they
were like oh yeah that was ni spe I go
right in some [__] green bowl that
had that probably tastes like Cascade
[__] whip that up yeah I didn't start
eating salads till about four years ago
so that was all that was all lost on
those things are all right man [__]
ready to eat [__] everything's in
there right into a wooden Bowl that's
just been destroyed by the dishwasher
it's love that white we never we were
the green like the [__] it it looked
like like [__] iceberg lettuce on the
side oh yeah we got one of those also
puked in it when you were
sick that's what got placed next to you
on a
couch [__] that Ken is going to taste
a little different tomorrow ma ew that's
gross yeah Patty has a cool like it's a
whole ball of lettuce like a whole head
of lettuce but it has a lid on it too
mhm keeps her weed in
there [__] Greenery
baby trying to stay
lit oh
God dip it into the dog CBD pills look
out uh anyway we were talking about
something we were talking about the back
of the paper trying to see see who got
jammed up oh yeah that and dude a nice
police scanner back in the day yeah we
never re we've had one we never my
stepdad had one to I mean we've talked
about a about CB radio I [__] love my
uncle red would sit there with that
[__] scanner and a couple of [__]
stemmers and just [__] be on the
watch dude we drive down the waiting for
some action it was my stepdad me in the
middle and my brother of a Ford
Ranger and he Shi all stiff and he's
between my legs shifting cuz like I'm
like [__] I a fat [__] eight-year-old
or whatever so dude I'm in the middle
you're like sticking his yeah dude man
eating sunflow eating that was the first
time I ever seen barbecue sunflower seed
oh my God [__] blow your tits off
those things start playing ball oh I was
just ducking him yeah those things are
he got a nugget or something [__] put
him on top uh yeah and the CB radio he's
cranking Winston man heater in a car a
ain't nothing to shake a stick at but
the biggest dirt ball thing I ever did
off those menus uh of the diner place
mats blew my mind and that's when I
really lost faith in certain kind of
advertising it was like mattress
warehous or like you know half half
whatever bottom line price
on couches or whatever of course it
doesn't work just to keep your you know
keeping good with the local community I
called the guy it was on there I needed
like a mattress or a cat I want to say
it was a mattr I needed a mattress and I
called this guy and he's [__] loser
what nobody calls those I did what did
he say I was jammed up I was looking for
like an $80 mattress he's at the table
next to you hello can I help you he's
taking my order hold on let me take
this I got a fat bastard spilled his
chocolate milk all over the place mat
hello youve reached Dan's mattress and
eggs what happened he's like yeah yeah
yeah when can you come by I'm like I
don't know I could be there in an hour
he's like that don't work for me I'm
like what that's there was no store he
just had a a garage full of furniture
wait so you were at a diner I was at a
diner woofing Down breakfast lunch what
are you at a little bit of both probably
you know what I mean how old are you 17
maybe and you were in the market for
what a mattress a m probably 18 I think
I was going to college J in CAU maybe 19
you were in charge of getting that stuff
yourself your mattress wait hold on who
needs a mattress for school your
freshman year you sleep in a door that's
what I'm saying it might have been my
sophomore
year Jesus yeah that's [__] what
Patty's the part I'm going to get shot
well this is the this I mean we go this
is the Crux between both of us I go and
do stuff you wait till Patty does it you
get shot down by Dan in the Mattress Man
I got Patty straighten me out with a c
of sleeper Queen let's go yeah right you
probably sold for drugs after after
three classes don't unwrap that don't
take that tag off
neither
uh plenty of room on the
floor uh I went I'm like all right and
he's like yeah you can meet you there
too I'm like meet me there like I was
like what the [__] dude and sir I'm a
businessman I don't have time for this
[__] sitting at a diner making your
business calls still cranking heaters
and I had I three bucks in the Jukebox
too I was [__]
cooking soon as this old heart of mine's
over I'll be at your
place uh yeah so I I went and he was
like he's like it's one two three main
street or whatever and I had known the
street I'm like that's that's a setup
I'm like that's an industrial park I'm
like I don't think there's no
storefronts down there man it was like
that scene from [__] Casino he was
like you had to keep going good no it's
Casino mm good
Fellas Ken to get a little further down
a little further down oh [__] yeah I was
thinking of Sharon Stone you're right
yeah man Bo you want to be my mattress
guy you're
nuts this guy don't know what's going on
uh man I'd like turn the say it was like
kachunk like the lights went on and
[__] I was like oh [__] dude did they
have the goods they were all just
wrapped up in plastic which I assume
they were used and I was just like all
right man yeah this is looks you have to
in that I I'm a nice guy where I can't
go oh [__] this I'm out I'm like oh yeah
this looks all right I got to check my
budget call Patty you know his whole
thing and I just [__] scadaddle
[__] buying your [__] garage
mattress [__] kick rocks it's all
right all right great question yeah home
run all right this one's from Jeff new
member from Miami shout out to you
haircuts in the front yard question mark
the B gives me a haircut in the front
yard saving money from the barber shop
and no clean up like you'd have to do it
if you were
inside I would say that's a backyard
activity to me to me if you want to do
it I would hope she has some sort of
skill to it as well it does paint a nice
picture though a nice Saturday afternoon
you're out in the front yard it depends
on the front yard you know what I mean
it depends where the front yard is a lot
of people front yard the front yard's in
the front buddy a lot of people do
operate in the front yard they put the
pool out there where it's legally okay
or maybe not um that kind of stuff
that's back those are backyard
activities you're nuts to try to say
front yard stuff I'm saying some side
maybe some people operate in the front
yard it depends how the house is
position I would say dirt bags yeah okay
that's all I'm saying I thought you were
spinning to be like it's okay it ain't
okay that's a back that's a side yard at
bet garage do it in the garage yeah
sweep up do it in a bathroom n do it in
a tub R run the [__] I think the
classiest place to get an inome cut is
in the kitchen that's where you would
normally get a cut that's where Patty
any time Patty ever did some some other
broad's hair was done in the kitchen I
get that you're not wrong that makes
sense that was always a fun night but
then that's where you're cooking though
I just thought of that it doesn't matter
to clean it up Patty you never clean it
up all the way one of Patty's friends
from work would come over and she'd do
somebody's roots oh [__] goofing
around laughing couple of candies
floating around probably show up with an
enman yeah then you got hair in your
cereal in the morning [__] that dude no
way uh-uh no hair in no that's a bathro
push you getting high off that hair dye
too that's bath that's bathroom [__]
turn your lights out
um yeah I used to have a friend who cut
hair and she would say she's like the
after a day she worked at the hair
cutter shout out to you had a whole crew
of G shout out to the Hair Cuttery um
couple of dime pieces work there back in
the
day shout out to the Plymouth be mall
they said there'd be hair everywhere
like all down their boobs and stuff like
all like cuz it's just you're just
cutting all day especially the hair
cutters like a Chop Shop they're running
and gunning in there you know what I
mean it's a numbers game it's like the
Boiler Room in there they're burning and
turning baby let's go ain't no money in
you sitting here got got to get someone
else in uh and they were like it'd be
it's everywhere it's all down our boobs
it's in our un like it just [__] CHR
yeah turn me on I what you
say uh but I would say knock that [__]
off in the front yard unless you got to
do that stuff in the backyard in the
Privacy a little bit of privacy it's
also like the backyard you can do
whatever you want in the backyard as as
long as you're not bothering but you're
in the front people walking by the
mailman's coming up you're getting a
haircut but this is what I'm saying I'm
trying to articulate it but I'm not
sometimes the front front yard is the
culture a little bit you do get to see
people coming by if everybody's all
friends maybe they have the little kitty
pool out front where the kids are
swimming and I'm not saying that's not
the case I understand what you're saying
but it's trashy we're here to determine
if classy or trashy and that's [__]
trashy front yard front yard haircut is
happening in one of those foldable beach
chairs that's like metal and then it's
like the lattice like Nyon you know
woven slice you up man I remember
getting caught in a couple of those when
I was a kid especially the the the long
ones where you'd lay out oh yeah the
ones that were like rubber or like
plastic but they were like plastic
threading mhm I got my foot caught in
there one time I a bear trap split your
chin open dude likeing Rusty ass [__]
uhhuh 90% of front yard haircuts are
mullets sure yeah it's not a good yeah I
would say trun to Mullet nothing but the
other 10% is bll Cuts ah we did it on
the back deck when Denise would cut the
hair it would be the back deck she give
you a bowl cut no she would shave just
buzz in the summer the whole thing yeah
she put it yeah oh really I told you one
time she put a number one in the back of
my head go
Kippy she really we're going to win this
year gang number one yeah what I don't
know just she [__] I mean she was
like a did you ask her yeah I mean she
yeah she not just [__] I'm surprised
she Catholic lady like that would would
allow that it was the summer summer was
all right she's not going to send me to
school like that like some [__]
Heathen wait a second wait a second wait
a second was it was the number one
shaved in or was the number one shaved
around what do you mean was it was the
one longer or shorter than the rest of
it shorter no she shaved my head she's
not a cattle that's insane she's not
that
good I me what are you
nuts cleaning you up J see that guy that
gets the horse in the side of his head
that guy's all right no she shaved it
let's call it like a one or a two or
something and then took the straight
like just the Clippers and just did like
one like it was like a a one with a
little
hat it's all just straight lines I mean
there's no real artwork it's you know
the pound I think it was like number one
wait she put a pound sign in there too
uhhuh # number one baby in case you
forgot your McDonald's order M what do I
want to all we got you yo this is my
dumbest
son this is number one idiot in the
family my brother got something too
lines in his eyebrow probably got a
two tell you idiots
apart
H damn look at you probably were beating
him off with a stick that some weren you
I think I was
six that's the trashiest [__] I ever
heard yeah was on the back deck I
remember it being 400° and me just
sweating [__] I have like a black a
comforter over me or something to catch
the hair I feel like you stood up and
then immediately lost a
race that boy right there PR
professional
athlete idiot
I got lines in the side of my head one
time right before Easter Sunday and man
the day freaked the [__] out Henry
you're too fast I hit it I hit it for a
week what I just I stayed on this side
of him how you doing Mom I swear to God
maybe not a week a couple of days I got
away with it I think I had it done on
Friday and by Sunday they were like
there's something what the [__] that was
back in the back in those time you could
avoid your parents pretty if school
school was happening there were working
either earlier they're gone like one of
them's gone in the morning yeah the
other one might be gone when you come
home still so there's only like a 2hour
perer if you can if you can just tell
them you crink your neck or something
when you're at dinner some [__]
tackle football got me [__] Jimmy o'
halan wearing a winter hat in this I
think my brother did that with his ear
pierced one time that's tough to hide
yeah I think he tried he had his eyebrow
pierced I think he tried to do it with
like he pulled like a beanie over it or
something man I'm pretty sure my dad
ripped that out of his head what are you
a dock
worker uh all right let's see here uh
this is from Hugh Jaz classic like it uh
is it garbage to buy a Bernie's T-shirt
If you never smoked Teeters I respect it
but don't start appreciate the support
baby shout out to you uh I was rocking
my heater t-shirt
yesterday um all right let's see this is
from granddaddy trip XX is it trashy to
take the doors off a car that's not a
Jeep to go cruising around town I feel
like more people are doing that these
days am cars I have never seen it like
you you take the door off in a cord yeah
I think people are doing that that seems
hard I would assume right illegal for
sure yeah you need one of those one of
those like air compressor ratchet guns
to do that you know what I'm talking
about like the ones that use on like in
like you can't just do that no you can
that's just yeah no you can you could I
feel like you need to like like you know
what I'm saying like see what you're
saying factory installed is what you're
saying how is that not illegal in a jeep
but it's can you get eyes on that why
it's illegal to take the doors off on a
Jeep and not a regular car maybe it's
not illegal that's a safety thing
kids cuz if you're in an accord and you
take the door off if you get
T-boned you're [__]
done something uh in New York it's
perfectly legal really take the doors
off your
car but you can't that's it I'm doing it
you can't do it in uh n PA though huh
state to state really yeah huh thought
this was America Jesus I want to drive
around all my doors off according to
this this article from 98.1 the hawk is
that true yeah that's what they saying
981 98.1 the hawk didn't you joke around
about that yeah we did uh chainer yeah
me and shout out to Ryan chainer we did
90 it was based off your Bozo buddies
Foley was one of those guy he was very
uh Kramer from Seinfeld he was always
talking about these friends that no one
ever saw or heard of or anything and
they always had the weirdest names in
the world you know this is my friend
like Bob sacamano and like like he would
tell us these stories so me and Shane
are just made up a whole universe where
the all your imaginary friends
live 981 point in the hawk huh is it
okay um that's D don't be doing that I
have your like
cruising
in a Beach town or something or in like
the desert sure can't think of what
other car you would do it for or that
you would definitely have to cut some
Bronco no yeah Bronco that makes sense
but a regular car you got to cut some
some wires that go into that car for the
doors and [__] they might those plugs
like those like uh like the the lights
like the Fe plastic female to male Joon
man you ever do those you feel you feel
like you're bra Cruz Mission Impossible
stuff yeah those are all right yeah even
when it was the old like all the old
batteries for like Power Wheels or or uh
remote control cars all had
that like a real scientist did you have
a Power Wheels as a kid
no I did red Jeep I'm pretty sure it was
used would have got rid you on the spot
if you did there's some videos Power you
had one I think it was
used saw a great video of a dad souping
must be nice I'm pretty sure it was my
dad's last itch effort to keep the
family together like yeah this this will
smooth things over everybody got one no
oh I I got one I saw a great a great
video of a dad souping up the a Barbie
Power Wheels Jeep for his daughter he's
like this thing thanks SW swaps the
engine out and then it cuts to her
drifting out of like a [__]
six-year-old drifting some of those can
do that seen that awesome yeah she knows
what she's doing hell killing in that
thing [__] whiping work yeah shout
out to always wanted one of those so bad
I thought I would be able to go anywhere
with it I thought once I got that dude
but in the actuality I'd be hitting the
open road you can't even drive through
grass in them the old ones were like
you'd be cruising in the drive like this
is pretty good you hit the guy and then
the battery's out yeah yeah you make it
till about the end of the culdesac uhhuh
and that's a I tell you what in a big
wheel though man talk about whipping
work what's the big wheel the the big
front with the two back yeah yeah dude I
had one of those puppies coming down
[__] red maple La look out they
yeah they were sliding the whole way
they were a little outdated by the time
I was a kid they they were huge where I
was kid we had one my brother had one
like a you know was like a hand me- down
from somebody but those things the tires
used to [__] get all they the plastic
tires would lose the tread you ever
remember those that's what that's what
it was cool for I know you slide but I
remember my buddy had one and was like
you could see into the top like dude
this thing ain't [__] we got to get we
got to inspect this thing got to run
this through the [__] the state
inspector or something [__] I pull the
permits on this thing you pay for these
stickers getting these
things oh man my brother had the sickest
one it was a Batman one the Batmobile it
that was the big one tight that was the
big one tight my my my buddy also had
they had two I don't know where the [__]
they got them I think they like trash
picked them or something uh they were
scooters but with like bike tires on
them like 80s scooters oh I know exactly
what you're talking about those things
were awesome they had brakes on them too
[__] they were called something can you
Google it 80s scooters with uh tires
they had like yeah they were like
probably the size of this can the tires
were yeah and man they had like it was
like a skateboard deck in the middle
yeah they had like the it was like a
bike half bike half skateboard kind of
yeah that they they're making them again
they're like they're calling them like
the flashback too and stuff but I'm not
getting the original like a like a Razer
or something like that no it was way
before they might have just no but I
mean that's that's the name I yeah Razer
and Mongoose are are
are I think like GT made them
you might be they were like bike esque
they had like the gyro on them they had
the bike cables yeah they were sick man
they had them and I've I couldn't buy
them in stores the GT
Zoot maybe that was it white mag wheels
oh yeah yeah man those things do you
ever have mags yeah I had them on one
bike one bike I was like 15 when when
they finally got it for me it was a GT
Pro Performer I hardly ever used it what
color it was like with the mags
white they were white the bike was like
baby blue with uh red
neon uh writing it was sick dude but I
never wor I was I was literally about to
start [__] start driving start
getting some tont Tang yeah uh Huffy my
whole life then I'm about to get out of
prison you get me that are mag wheels
the three spokes plastic oh yeah yeah
that was always that was always poser
[__] for me I was like Dave Mir ain't
rocking that yeah but I think they were
more uh they were more dirty at that
like it was like dirt I think they were
like dirt they became popular with my
generation when ET dropped cuz one of
the kids in ET had yellow mag wheels it
was more of like a style it was you
weren't doing tricks it was more like
check me out it was it was a choice I
was telling you the other day you guys
you might have caught this when they
were selling bikes with the inside was
completely closed in there were like
huge discs on the tires I think they
were like speed stuff there was one bike
in particular that had it cuz my cousin
had the bike it was a BMX bike but it
was completely enclosed it looked real
futuristic but they would they they were
so [__] heavy I was going to say suck
they were like they were like the tires
on the cop cars in Robocop okay yeah
yeah I got you yeah um they stunk I
remember one with just one kid I don't
know where who what school he went to we
would just see him from time he would
just come looping around at like
whatever shopping center we were hanging
out at he had red mags and we're like
dude this guy will
[__] this guy [__] dude who drives
around with red mags he had like a
mustache when he was like 14 you know
what I mean one of those kids hope he's
out there listening to this yeah shout
out to you man the bikes next to him
uhhuh still it's upside down he's
spinning the tires yeah he do they knew
they knew everybody saw that and uh that
that reminded me too we we so we used to
uh hang out in a lot of uh uh shopping
centers one particular sure that was
where like all of we' get our bikes and
we go the hang out there you could get
there you get slice of pizza you go in
the woods smoke weed smoke a heater
there was like we called them half pipes
too they were like in the kind of like
the retention basins you would see them
are like white or concrete you know what
I mean they're like flat I don't know
you might not have them down the water
would come out yeah it was like an an
overflow thing for water to let water if
like a ditch no how would you call call
them they were retaining ponds they'd be
like underneath like an overpass and
then they would have a they would have a
tunnel that would come out where the
water would go they were like kind of
self-made uh half pipes but they had
like hard edges to them and they were
usually like white like a jersey barrier
what's a jersey barrier uh Jersey
Barrier is those the the big concrete
slabs that they'll they'll put for like
road work and stuff where they're where
they're kind of B on the bottom no no no
no this is this is the mouth of
where a tube where water would shoot out
like the tube would be like this big
okay and it was it was he's from [__]
North Carolina they probably riding over
wagon covered
bridges the [__] wagon that's not even a
thing wagon covered bridges jumping over
Hogs uh we did jump we did have a lot of
jumps over cracks sure shout out to a
nice cck love it um but we would go till
the rains came oh
chcken there was always a story there
was always a story of little Timmy from
three schools over we we would jump into
them when it was like that oh yeah that
was well one you had to so dangerous you
had to test the water if you slipped you
were going up against the grate
underneath the thing coming out the
other
end [__] turned into spaghettio room
jammed you
up [__] pasta all of Foley um but not
to mention the bacteria that must have
been in there oh I dude the back I mean
we just we were just in anytime there
was some sort of stagnant body of water
we like we should get in there just
[__] jump just jump out of a tree
ride your butt throw football D we were
treating them like they were above
ground pools we didn't give a [__] um
but I remember the one kid we used to uh
an older kid we used to buy sigs from he
drove uh a red T Toyota Turell the
hatchback I mean it was old this is
probably 99 red Toyota Tel 2001 all
right I got this is probably like a 91
like this is already old for then like
almost a doson yes very doony and he had
a system in
it that guy pulls into Village hour's
parking lot you go dead ringer buying me
heaters if there's anybody in this
parking lot is going to buy me heaters
it's going to be this guy oh yeah dude
he got out he we he looked like Vin
Diesel we called him Vin Diesel and
we're like yo [__] I bumped Vin
Diesel was in chers last night I was
able to get a Sig man he would get out
he was the kind of guy parking leave the
[__] radio blasting leave the door
open looking for a fight when you could
do that man I was that was that was a
more civilized time he Le cranking in a
7-Eleven [__] trunks rattle mirrors
falling off [__] dude going in there
for a Big Gulp and a big bite let's go
making noise wanting to be seen baby I
respect it uh and then this [__] uh
yeah right away started buying a and he
never there was people who knew they
were breaking the law would be chill
about it right I mean we're like 13 like
we're not even like hey I'm 16 my
parents let me smoke I can't get heaters
whatever like we were like 13 you know I
have [__] hair on my balls yet and
I'm asking him for sigs and he made a
spect what you bump in y what do you
need marble lights like [__] knock it
off dude [__] fuzzes everywhere this
place is littered with cops what are you
talking about [__] they're on the
steak out trying to catch me buying
heaters dude he didn't care shout out to
that guy yeah the tcell old school man I
like it uh all right let's see here uh
this one's from Thomas
Mullen close close but no cigar first
time long time is a garbage if your mom
picks you up from a DUI and just says
well you're trying your
best man that's not the first time you
[__] up you're at you're at the wrong
end of a lot of bad decisions right
there Jesus Christ oh you're trying
imagine getting a DUI and your mom going
well you're trying like buddy you ain't
that's the you almost made it
home that's tough that's a tough look
yeah that's you get your act together
there that's a mom with a couple dewis
herself yeah she gets it she's been
jammed up in there oh this is Debbie's
kid you know what I
mean
I'll come down pick you up I got your
mom doing she's still off the
hooch yeah she's known at that yeah I
mean that's a getting arrested with your
mom that's bad that's a tough look ah
yeah I don't I mean I've never been
arrested KN on war never even brought in
no man
questioning no they used to call it was
a joke I mean I've said this before they
used to call me the Teflon Dawn because
whenever cops came I never got caught
they were like this is [__] I would
just stand there and be the only thing
that stuck to you was
baloney this fat kid's got enough
problems a tlon I mean obviously it's a
joke I wasn't walking around thinking I
was giving out turkeys a Christmas
somebody find Vin Diesel give me a bag
of heaters no it was uh I just never I'd
always just got high school party I
always got dude I always got passed by
in the in the shuffle in the mix
honestly you didn't have high school
parties where the cop showed up and
everybody had a run 100% And your fat
ass got away I either got away or the
ones where I didn't the one time I
didn't have my ID on me and they were
like all right just stand over there and
wait and then like they processed
everybody else and just
forgot put a lame shade on your head
what happened to that fat [__] and they
with the one in his head they just
forgot about me okay and then same and
then another time we got hit by the
state troopers down at the Philadelphia
Troopers Troopers got us at at Citizens
Bank par oh I remember you telling me
about this and they just they [__] it
was so made you dump the beer right four
cases I think man there is nothing more
terrifying than a [__] Pennsylvania
state trooper or any state trooper for
that matter uhhuh Jesus what if I wasn't
a trooper it feels like you're going
straight to prison uh and then I just
didn't they just P they just like I two
times where like I did get jammed up and
didn't get away like I go okay you got
me I'll bite the bullet whatever ever it
is they [__] just never wrote me up
never never filled out the paperwork I
got jammed up talking to a State Trooper
who was security at our prom for some uh
nefarious allegations against a couple
two three friends of mine about how we
got there Etc and man the first 10
minutes was okay but I was on a [__]
headful of asset that kicked in as I was
in mid conversation with this
guy
W you want a [__] up a Friday night Toby
hello [__] perjuring yourself in
front of the man on a head full of
sunshine I'm not going to lie to you sir
you got two faces right now are all
three you going to arrest
me can you do me a favor and stand still
you can the you and the other worm
people
could give me a second if we're done
here you don't have jurisdiction on this
planet they brought they brought me out
once they were like how did this this
and this happen I'm like I don't know
ever blah blah blah but have you ever
thought about the concept of love man
then like an hour later they yanked me
at again they yelled my they called my
name over the loudspeaker they were
[__] grilling me again looking at
your boy probably elbow deep into finger
foods at that point dude I Hade
eightball
eyes [__] yikes well we got pinched
at uh at my buddy's house at a party
yeah they just took us down they scare
you got to give you the rabble Rouser um
yeah I was the only one who never got
caught uh you
know yeah should have a bunch of times
for being an idiot um but just uh luck
of the draw you know racketeering
illegal gambling operation goddamn RICO
charge you are the Teflon
Don uh not to mention the payoff money
dude the one when the TR it's just
kippy's picture on a corkboard down the
precinct how we got to [__] bag of
bag of Blue Magic next to him we got we
got to cut the head of the snake off a
chicken tender on the wall
uh the flat breed freak strikes again
I'm running out on tabs all over town
columbos out there looking for you one
more fla um uh the worst when the when
the [__] the state troopers got the
gang that was the worst that wasn't just
like those guys don't [__] around dude
they everybody had to do they are
intimidating cuz I think we were still
we were still underage did they have the
uniforms on on no undercover Penn State
jerseys Philly jerseys they got out uh
and they were like when they wear those
military those like uh drill sergeant
hats dude buddy I ain't no Cadet all
right yeah they're frightening uhhuh
it's like major pain all over again A
lot of times they have no sense of humor
no they L and I had a buddy who was a
State Trooper uh and dude I caught him
in his [__] gear they wear that chin
strap that just like covers their mouth
that's what I'm saying buddy relax
[__] what are you doing grab a couple
coffee yeah they they're real that's
real I mean I think that you know that's
an honorable thing it's real of course
[__] prim and proper and they they
they check the they Jersey state
troopers they don't [__] around on that
turn bike I'll tell you that um but when
I got when I got when everybody else got
got they all had to go through like they
had to do like 40 hours community
service and [__] that sucks this is
like an adult like we were in college
and they had to like drive back down to
the city to do some sort of [__] uh
uh drinking class like it wasn't just
like pay a fine and [__] move on it
was like it was like months of [__]
[__] yeah my one buddy got sent away
to [__] rehab for [__] like 3
weeks or something like that or like a
month my other one had to do it like
locally for smoking herbs no knocking
over Banks beers they really I don't
know I wonder what they do now about
underage it's got to be a little less
probably what [__] Thro what are you
crazy when I was a kid when when in my
in like jior high in high school when
kids were getting knocked that was when
all that like just throw the [__]
book at like it was like crazy like [__]
you would get for like one underage
drink and if you had like two beers
they'd throw the [__] book at you
like it it wasn't I'm assuming that's
gotten a little I don't think so that's
when all those [__] that was all like
state run [__] that they all had or
privately run [__] that the state was
sending people to they were getting
[__] Kickbacks on it that I don't
think all that shit's happen I'm sure
like you get jammed up some but I mean
it was I could be wrong completely but
it was [__] I wonder if they still
throw the [__] up car in front of the
high school you guys have that they did
that for me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
just use your
car he could have [__] driving by
things nicer than mine I was scoping it
out took the tires off
it take them doors off you'd be all
right done with that head unit
pal God damn but we got to wrap it up
gang this was a fun one yeah was a hoot
gang we love you to death grab your tick
check out rug garbage.com check out the
patreon all that good stuff we love you
and we'll see you next week peace peace